le fait que le président de la
république remplacer finalement un
énarque de droite par un autre énarque
de droite jean castex il incarne quoi le
changement la continuité la continuité
dans le changement le changement dans la
continuité
non je pense qu'ils incarnent les
territoires il incarne cette
décentralisation c'est une nouvel acte
de la décentralisation voulue par
président de la république pour donner
aussi plus de pouvoir et plus de
responsabilité aux collectivités
territoriales alors moi en tant que
sénateur je ne peux que m'en satisfaire
c'est vrai que c'est une autre façon de
s'exprimer une autre façon peut-être
peut-être plus pédagogique même si
j'avais beaucoup de steam pour pour
edouard philippe qui était peut-être
parfois un peu cassant avec un certain
nombre d'opposants mais je pense que
jean castex et il l'a rappelé est apaisé
la france faire en sorte de reprendre
aussi ce dialogue social qui qui avait
qui existait un soudeur philippe mais
qui qui avait peut-être été un peu
rompus au moment des grèves
donc je pense que moi en tant que
social-démocrate autant dire que le
directeur philippe mais ils l'ont dit
edouard philippe
et le président de la république la
république l'a d'ailleurs redit non lors
de son discours pour pouvoir incarner un
nouveau cap dans le quinquennat il
fallait changer aussi de premier
ministre et ça c'est d'un commun accord
entre d'anciens premiers ministres le
président de la république on peut pas
changer de cap faire un virage social et
écologiste sans avoir un changement de
l'équipe
vous le voyez ce virage vous le voyez
clairement ce virage social et
écologique mais moi je le vois notamment
sur la question de la jeunesse qui est
un indispensable quand on voit qu'on à
700 milles à huit cent mille jeunes qui
vont arriver sur le marché de l'emploi à
partir de septembre et qu'on n'avait pas
de solution alors ce qu'on est en pleine
crise économique
pleine crise sociale effectivement les
propositions aujourd'hui qui sont sur la
table lors du discours de politique
générale qui est dont une partie
d'ailleurs on vont être mis en oeuvre
dans le projet de loi de finances
rectificative vous dans ce sens là on
soutient justement à cette jeunesse pour
qu'il n'y ait pas une jeunesse sacrifiée
comme on pouvait s'y attendre
pourtant il ya certains parlementaires
qui ont votre parcours d'anciens
socialistes qui ne s'y retrouvent pas
aujourd'hui ils disent on va continuer
avec la réforme des retraites on va
peut-être deux
demander des efforts aux français pour
eux le virage écologiste socialiste
n'existe pas quand le premier ministre
indique qu'il veut réindustrialiser la
france fer de que la réindustrialisation
de la france passe aussi par la
transition écologiquement c'est ça que
je vois moi je vois aussi une volonté
aujourd'hui d'aller sur cette transition
écologique quand je vois effectivement
les milliards que nous mettons sur la
table pour soutenir la jeunesse pour
quand on voit le plan ségur qui est un
plan bien sûr jamais satisfaisant pour
ceux qui subissent au quotidien les le
manque de financement de l'hôpital mais
8 milliards pour la revalorisation des
carrières 6 milliards d'investissements
dans les villes et dans les hôpitaux
voilà c'est aussi ça c'est aujourd'hui
des mesures inédites
la dernière fois qu'on a revalorisé le
personnel je crois que c'était un grand
plan d'envergure c'était rocard en 91
donc je vous dirais ya quand même trente
ans on n'a rien fait pour le personnel
soignant donc c'est effectivement des
mesures inédites des mesures sociales et
des mesures indispensables aujourd'hui
on va revenir un peu plus tard sur
effectivement ce plan de relance
économique mais puisque vous parliez
d'écologie il y a eu
nicolas hulot il ya eu françois de rugy
maintenant barbara pompili est-ce
qu'elle va pouvoir réellement agir on
dit que le ministère de l'écologie c'est
un peu le ministère maudit je pense pas
aujourd'hui elle est numéro deux du
gouvernement s'est aussi de montrer que
que cette question est centrale dans la
politique du gouvernement
elle vient aussi de la gauche elle vient
des écologistes mais de la gauche
aujourd'hui du gouvernement elle est
d'ailleurs membre d'un d'un mouvement au
sein de la majorité présidentielle et
d'une sensibilité au sein de l om qui
s'appelle en commun qui assume ce côté
social démocrate écologiste
d'ailleurs nous on a des discussions
entre territoires de progrès et avec
l'ailé gauche de la majorité
donc non je pense qu'au contraire elle
est là la volonté d'agir et je pense
surtout qu'il ya une prise de conscience
de l'ensemble de nos dirigeants sur
cette question écologistes et je pense
qu'il est indispensable aujourd'hui que
toutes nos politiques publiques et ce
fil rouge de la transition écologique